thank you are gonna put to the organizer
for the mutation and this is also
welcome to the shortest talk of the
workshop I only task for 10 minutes but
I was given 15 so I don't know what to
do with all this time right great and
there is an ask only for 10 minutes
worse because you know when once I have
such a bold claim in my title as here
who does as notice then you know how can
I convince her this is the simplest
product for your answer by presenting it
in in a very short amount of time so so
this is joint work with tongue - who is
a PhD student at the end of in' and so
first of all abuse transfer this
audience shouldn't I don't need to
introduce abuse and to the audience but
maybe there is someone following us in
streaming who's doesn't know what the
blue is transfer is so ot is this
beautiful cryptographic primitive where
you have a sender which messages m0 and
m1 and the receiver with some choice bit
B and and at the end of the protocol
they receive the receiver blames the
message MB and they say intuitively or
Onofre mama informally the security
requirements for abuse transfer is that
the sender should not learn what the
choice between at the same time the
receiver should not learn anything about
the other message the message as it
doesn't choose and why do we care about
the biggest transfer so so first of all
abuse transfer is very interesting
because it's the necessary and
sufficient tool for multi-party
computation at least in the case of
dishonest majority for most interesting
functionalities and and is also used
extensively in practical protocols such
as yoga but circuit protocol where you
need to use one oblivious transferred
for each bit of the input and in
protocols like Jim W where you have one
oblivious transferred for each
multiplication gate inside the protocol
and so on
you have protocol for private set
intersection multiplication protocols
like Thomas was presenting yesterday we
use which usability transfer so it's
very interesting to study that the
efficiency of abuse transfer the bad
news is that oblivious transfers
provably probably requires public key
type assumptions and therefore
efficiency so bill stands for is
inherently
an inefficient kind of object so you can
we cannot hope to 2w is transferred
based only on cheap symmetric
cryptography such as block cipher or
hash functions but luckily we can extend
oblivious transfer and if you never
heard of abuse transfer extension you
I'm sure that everyone here everyone is
knows about hybrid encryption so so what
do you do in practice is that you don't
use public encryption right in most in
most protocols you use public encryption
to encapsulate some symmetric key and
then you use the symmetric key to
encrypt your big file and the same thing
essentially you can do it WB's transfer
you can do a number of oblivious
transfers some seed oblivious transfer
some some basil babies transfer and then
which require public key technology and
then you can extend those to any
polynomial number of oblivious transfers
using only symmetric key operation and
this has been shown by beaver in 96 and
then if shy at all in 2003 show that
this can be done efficiently for passive
security and and and recent work even
shows that this can be done very very
efficiently even against active
adversaries also for with malicious
acuity and just to give you an idea so
those are some numbers taken by the work
of a sheriff that's all from the zero to
decrypt there are some even better
number in an upcoming paper from by
Marcel Keller at all and you know Marcel
should tell you something about it
during one of the discussion session
tomorrow but just to give you an idea of
the order of magnitude so if you want
passive security you can you can perform
anybody's transfers where the amortized
cost is essentially one microsecond so
the order of magnitude is that you can
perform a million abuse transfer per
second using what the extension and this
is great but of course as you know as I
breathe encryption doesn't remove the
need for for some good public encryption
scheme probably this transfer extension
doesn't remove the need for for some
good base abuse transfer protocol so you
know the one that I use in this face or
even you know maybe sometimes you only
want to do one or two bleep is transfer
so what the extension is not it's not
relevant so and there have been a lot of
proposal for for protocol for abuse
transfer and and some of them
similars that to the one I'm going to
present at those of bal-ri McCauley and
our pink ass which unfortunately are not
known to achieve simulation-based
security which is the minimum level of
security if you want any kind of
guarantee in a concurrent setting or in
for some kind of composition and then
you have more recent protocols probably
most notably the one of packet we know
then and in waters which achieve you see
security but are more more complicated
than that than the original ones so I
want to go back to the beginnings and I
want to go all the way back to the final
man and the PM on key exchange so so I
hope that does a definite man at least
Google Images things so so you have some
sender with some message mm and you
brought some receiver and and what is
the defilement key exchange protocol do
so so Alice that the descender take some
some group element some generator of the
group raise it to some secret exponent X
and send the result to Bob Bob takes the
same generator raise it to some other
secret exponent and send it back to
Alice now they both derive some
symmetric key by hashing this this group
element so Alice computes as Y to the X
and Bob computes with X to the Y which
two elements are the same they both they
can both hash this element derives from
some symmetric key and then Alice can
send the message encrypted using this
key and Bob can can decrypt the message
so everyone should be fine with this
it's after lunch but you know this is
this should be fine for this audience so
essentially the main observation that
that you know the only thing you should
remember now is that there is another
key which Bob cannot compute at the end
of the film and case change there is a
different key that Bob cannot compute if
you assume that the competition the film
on problem is hard and this key is
defined by Y divided by X big X raised
to the X so if you do the math here what
you get you get some G to the X square
so this is a linear combination of G to
the X Y and G to the x squared and G to
the X square is our to compute given
given access to only G to the X is our
to compute e to the X square and there
is a reduction of this problem to the
completion of the film on prop
great so so now that we have this other
key now we can use this other key to to
double use transfer so so now we W
stands for Alice's two messages m0 and
m1 Bob is some choice big B so let's
start like before so Alice sends G to
the X Bob sends you to the Y now Alice
derived two keys instead of one there
I've kid 0 by by following exactly the
diffie-hellman key exchange protocol and
then the other key but using this
element that Bob cannot compute and and
now use it uses these two key to
transfer the two messages to Bob and Bob
can decrypt of course now Bob as this
key this key corresponds to the two the
first one now so Bob can decrypt the
first message but not the second one of
course this only works when B is equal
to 0 what do you do when B is equal to 1
well you just adjust the key so so now
instead when Bob instead of sending G to
the Y since X times G to the Y which
means that if you replace this element
in here now you get that KB now is equal
to k1 because if you know twice big x
times 2 DG g to the y you remove the X
and you get the same element here in
here so now Alice and Bob you know
depending on the Bob choice beats Bob
sends either G to the wire X to the G to
the Y and now we're in this situation
where Bob can compute one of the two
keys and Alice doesn't know which one
it's clear that Alice doesn't know which
one because J to the Y if the group is
cyclic hides completely whether X is
there or not and Bob doesn't learn the
other message because Bob cannot compute
the other group element so this is this
is the intuition behind it
so which encryption in the crypt which
encryption scheme should we use here so
so it turns out that the property we
need to prove you see security are the
following so we need this this
encryption scheme to be non committing
meaning that the simulator given access
to a random cipher text and a message
and any message can compute card with a
key in such a way that the distribution
of you know a random key and an
encryption of the message on using this
key is indistinguishable from random
ciphertext and and and a key produced to
open that ciphertext to the particular
message another property we need is
robustness as studied by for instance
Abdallah at all in the sense that
and adversity it knows a number of keys
cannot produce a ciphertext that
decrypts correctly for both for more
than one of these secret keys so you
know think of a directory of secret keys
for your friends and you cannot make a
ciphertext that two of your friends will
decrypt correctly so how hard is to
construct such an encryption scheme is
actually very easy essentially it's just
one time pad with a little bit of
redundancy where lambda is the security
parameter and then the cripton simply
you know that you do the one-time pad
encryption checks check for the
redundancy check for the zeros and if
the zeros are there then then prime is
your message otherwise you abort that's
yeah yeah the keys are honesty generated
yeah so the keys are random keys so of
course here if the keys are random then
the probability that two of these keys
will share this this this T part is very
low and of course we only need to use
this encryption scheme once so which is
which is what that's the trick right so
so that does the work and so very
quickly so if the receiver is corrupted
what is the main one of the main
challenge in the proof is that you need
to extract the choice bit of the of the
of the receiver but in the in the run in
the random Oracle model the simulator
gets access to the query of
off Bob and now since since the
simulator knows X can compute the two
group elements which corresponds to the
two keys and I can just wait for Bob to
ask one of these two queries to the
Oracle and when Bob ask one of the two
queries to the Oracle you define is
choice beat to be the corresponding bit
right and you're sure that Bob is never
gonna ask for both queries because if
you ask for both queries is breaking the
that the composition if Elmen problem
and then you program the random Oracle
to make the corresponding ciphertext to
open to the message you get from the
real functionality to prove suit against
a corrupted sender instead one of the
main challenges is to extract the input
of the sender from the ciphertext and
what we do is that you simply I mean the
sender is asking for Chris to the random
Oracle so the simulator knows all the
keys that that that the sender has and
now you can just try to decrypt the
ciphertext using all the keys
that that that the sender God and and
and the messages are the only value
which is different than than this bottom
one so that was it we can prove that the
protocol is you see secure against
active and adaptive corruptions which
you should not be surprising because
they it's information theoretic I mean
the in the random Oracle model this
encryption scheme is non committing and
and we only need authenticated
point-to-point channels not even private
channels because the protocol already
dusted so they so half of this work has
been on actually doing some crypt
engineering on this protocol which was
where was very very important to work
with tank with an expert in elliptic
curves and then all the tricks that you
need to make protocol using elliptic
curve secure so so the protocol only
uses paddocks pronounciation and
communicates to group elements plus tube
ciphertext and an implementation uses
using this curve takes approximately
ANDed
microseconds for one ot and one y
amortized over for instance two hundred
Ortiz then it goes around a hundred
microsecond and I think one of the most
fun exercises in doing this you know
this is the conceptual bit of the talk
is that you know we have a protocol with
a proof of security that says you know
in the UC model this particle is secure
so a implies B but then of course the
real word the software that you design
that the softer the D right and and you
know and communication between computers
is running a procedure okay
the UC model is an approximation of
real-world computing not also the other
way around depends how you which so can
we claim any security of Khem can we
claim that I say that this protocol is
secure against active adversaries can I
claim that my implementation you secure
against active adversaries of course you
know that's like I don't have a theorem
for that but there a lot of interesting
tricks in the paper which are borrowed
by by you know all the literature on on
security of the fire monkey exchange
protocols and things are dead which
makes sure that the implementation is
cost some time it's secure against in
for messages against many the Middle's
and and i invite and i think this is
this is something which perhaps you know
quoting buddha from yesterday
a lot of the work that we have done in
inefficient secure computation in the
last years I said a lot of him the focus
was on making things faster and I think
some some you know to avoid you know
disasters in the future we should also
think about how this this about the
security of the protocols that we
implement right so that was it thanks
know in the you see mother the random
Oracle is like that like the setup
assumption is only visible inside the
product right so it's a local object is
not a public object right yeah yeah sure
yeah which means that when you implement
the protocol you need to make sure that
the random Oracle is to some extent
local to the protocol which is something
that we can I will be happy to discuss
offline about about heuristics of course
I mean no proof but how to Arista Kaleem
make sure that this random Oracle is as
local as possible to the protocol and
does not you know it's only look up to
the product for instance by using the
transcript of the protocol as input to
the random Oracle you can make sure that
that you know each instance of the
protocol uses essentially are different
but yeah you're absolutely right that's
that's exactly the point of this yeah
so can you reuse the same if you want to
make it two rounds I use again it's like
the signal exam that can you reuse the
same as the first message is the same to
some extent yes to the extent that that
we need to weaken the functionality a
little bit by giving so essentially so
the way extract that is the the bit of
the receiver is by so the receiver could
ask for the queries after is the
ciphertext so essentially if I when I
reuse the first element I need to ask
the function I to the bits one at a time
and it tracks the function I to allow
the receiver to ask for the for the
messages one at a time instead of I
cannot make sure that you do to transfer
which are independent to each other in
the area functionality which seems to be
a which is not an attack on the protocol
seems more to be an issue with the proof
right so I would but that that's there
is no series only random Oracle is big
enough is it strong enough so we can we
could take this offline I'm not entirely
sure that when you put that so that I
would implement a random common every
string in an implementation that's I
think that that's a very I'm not sure
that that there is a secure way of of
implementing Common Era string in any
you know reasonable way so but that's
something we should discuss
maybe later
thank you very much